the next voted upon one is here for
trailers revisited and that is Star Wars
The Force awakens a teaser trailer
remember how excited we all were when
this trailer first came out oh man it's
so back
oh what a long ass wait well guys I put
out in our community post sent on
patreon which title would be better
trailers revisited or trailer versus the
movie trailers revisited got the most
votes on the community page here on
YouTube but a patreon trailer vs. the
movie did going through all the comments
I realize it's really just a case by
case basis sometimes these are gonna
sound a little bit more like a revisited
where we're reflecting on oh yeah I
remember how different it felt the first
time to watch this of course still do in
some of the first in the movie
comparison comparing it and sometimes
gonna be a little bit more obvious like
Suicide Squad where it's very much a
trailer versus the movie breaking down
how hyper different it is something
tells me this one will be more of a
revisited type of video but I think it's
just safe to say we're keeping the title
revisited for now but who knows might
change it I'm indecisive
- being an awakening oh it's been so
long we felt it so ho because I've seen
this dream
Royalle thought fin would be the Jedi
like stormtroopers play
wow it's still get chills still get
nipple
Theatre
[Music]
what ain't perfect teaser trailer yeah
[Music]
what happened this this literally is
like the pinnacle of potential your
sound you know been a long time since
I've seen that trailer my god we really
have come along this is true that blew
up Tyrone Magnus who's already getting
popular but this is the one that really
skyrocketed remember that featured on
all those on the news and stuff
I'm a red-letter media's video making
fun of reactors for this one huh one of
their best videos ever launched a
thousand viral video yeah it feels like
this is forever ago considering the
trajectory considering Daisy Ridley's
latest comments of what happened to all
the love that we once had what happened
to all the hope and excitement that
everyone had for this it's sad I mean
cuz like force awakens came out and that
was it was good serviceable when I
rewatched it leading up to the last Jedi
and I watched them all in chronological
order it wasn't as good as I remembered
it being there so funny so this is fine
this was like the thing that was
instilling so much faith and who would
have thought that it would be the
trilogy here that would make people go
the prequels weren't that bad eventually
we'll get another you know it's a couple
installments of an official canon of
some kind and then we'll have a
renaissance where we look back and go
yeah but yeah like this is fascinating
because this is like the perfect blend
of things you have obviously some really
new imagery to start off you're in this
like really POV situation with the
stormtroopers which is a place that we
up until this point I don't think ever
went like just in the ship making them
actually look cool and badass and yeah
you have fin you have Rey you've got
just this promise of like oh yeah this
all looks like Star Wars stuff but it's
new and it's fresh and then we go into
you know stuff that we know already it's
funny because like the nostalgia here
with some hints and
characters but this trailer still
primarily leans into nostalgia it's
funny how nostalgia ultimately became
its demise - the thing is like it's all
here because you have like it's
literally nostalgia but with something
new like popping out it's like Finn is
inside the nostalgic suit Rey is in a
nostalgic desert on some kind of a junk
vehicle and then we have you know the
nostalgia over x-wings get it on a fight
you know in the name and the bb-8 was
like some people at first not ever most
people I wouldn't say most better there
were some who were like is that our 2d -
no there's a new upgraded r2d2 model but
then those in the know knew that it was
a completely different droid at the time
but then also hearing like the the voice
of the new villain ass being an
awakening Snoke overlapping this and
that kind of run shots not in the movie
at all and then come to think of it it's
a great shot and company oh Emily I
don't even know where that shot makes
sense because if you look at the rest of
it and you're like what's you looking at
yeah everybody is everybody there yeah
is that like a deleted scene that I have
just never stumbled upon this entire
time it's the moment where he's working
himself up he's like okay you go to be
as scary as possible when you actually
do it so maybe we'll crouch down you
know he's just practicing his you know
cuz he's not that bad of a guy yet in
the first movie he's still trying to
prove he's the big bad I guess the weird
thing about going back and watching this
specific trailer it's effective it's
still so effective like I was getting
chills
I think the immediacy of watching is so
great still and it's still thrilling
I feel like anytime I watch this trailer
now it's just gonna be followed by what
has become since this movie has come out
the shifts in the business with Star
Wars like the a at Row one yet solo the
relationship that's formed with Ike how
Disney has treated Star Wars and then of
course just the trilogy itself how we
were all so excited and thought that
they this would be the one that really
did it and you kind of just watch this
like went like up here to here - kind of
weird no-man's land in the middle yeah
but it's it's funny to me because this
movie force awakens isn't arguably the
most beloved Star Wars movie but it does
as the Reed
managed to be the most like good you
know it's satisfying to everybody it's
mostly nostalgic it's not new out there
and judging by you know the harsh
reactions to going a bit out there after
that and then having to clean that up it
seems ironic now that yeah the one
people dogged for not being that
original is probably the one people
would return to and have the best chance
of liking yeah and it also has you know
all that promise to and this trailer
doesn't even have it and it's funny to
me because I wasn't even thinking of it
up until right this moment but I was
like oh you've also got the original
cast returning you know that promise
back before any big plot spoilers any
life events happen you have Mark Hamill
and then Carrie Fisher and Harrison Ford
back and like the fact that you don't
even have that here is fascinating to me
because you just get the Falcon like the
Falcons the main piece the old cast that
you get it goes back to the puzzle box
and it's the bummer about the puzzle
boxes when you make a puzzle box like
this like it's the teaser and I love the
format of the teaser especially because
this is enough to sell me on a Star Wars
movie it's the atmosphere it's the
intensity it's the spirit you know after
that I can go in cold yeah I don't know
it's something about the way that this
dresses this puzzle box up so
beautifully and it's just there was no
plan like it's such a weird thing to
think about now because yeah the trailer
does get you completely excited to watch
this movie and to embark on a new
trilogy and to have that magic back yeah
and they're not honestly I think this
teaser trailer is more exciting than the
movie yeah alright even factoring the
trilogy I'm think I'm talking just the
force awakens I think this teaser
trailer is more exciting than the film
itself it's like that tent should be
like the dark spaces little images has
so much more dynamic than all said and
done I don't hate the trilogy I really
don't I like force awakens
I like last Jedi and flip flop between
Raisa Skywalker it's worth appreciating
it very least just kind of sad to know
cuz fandom factors in so much to Star
Wars to think of like Oh remember when
the fandom was like
and now yeah makes me wonder if there's
a future at all for the main episodic
stars because you think now like the
main creator had complete control for
the prequels and that single robbery and
then we gave it to like a new gatekeeper
for the sequels and that didn't go over
too right so maybe we should just leave
it because we can only all agree on the
original trilogy alright guys well how
does it make you feel to go back and
watch this trailer leave your thoughts
down below and also make sure to tell us
what else you'd like us to do a trailers
revisited for each one brings a
different kind of discussion subscribe
click that notification mother notified
never got a video up last but not least
TJ and J n gonna give two shout outs
here and to make this happen we thought
we've known some patients for a while so
it'd be fun if they met so John wrote a
little scene of TJ and J and meeting
each other I call TJ alright then I'm J
it is here we go TJ trakis and J and
Valente sit across the table from each
other are you gonna eat that
who's asking I am and who are you well
I'm TJ a patron of the real rejects who
are you
well I'm J N or at least that's what
other human beings call me although when
you really get right down to it what's a
name coming and going like ships in the
night with such frequency what matters
the nomenclature interesting so what
does J n stand for who wants to know I
do and who are you
welcome TJ interesting and what does
that stand for who wants to know I do
and who are you well I'm Jan or at least
that's what other human beings call me
although when you get right down to
interesting and what does that stand for
that's you luck eyes staring
unblinkingly at one another well it
would appear we'd have ourselves a
Mexican standoff I can't be what it
stands for
also that turn of phrase is sort of
outdated time on the count of three one
two three shudders dreams doughnuts
this is getting us nowhere you're right
well if you can't beat them join them
and that's how teach invit rocked a was
born
so you know here you have a future job
these guys are gonna have a very
memorable meeting so you what